so I'm a
I have a
chemistry but that translates reasonably
well into chemical engineering given the
research that I do my first effort in
energy research here or I suppose
leadership of Energy Research was to be
the point person putting together
Carnegie Mellon's relationship with the
Department of Energy's National Energy
Technology Laboratory so my research
area is really around surfaces reactions
on surfaces catalysis which is very much
central to petroleum and petroleum
energy conversion when you pump
petroleum out of the ground it comes out
as a black sludge and you can't just put
it into your car or put it into an
airplane it has to be converted which
means molecules have to be changed from
one form into another and that's the
essence of what we do is to try to
understand how catalytic materials like
platinum and zeolites and others are
able to take molecules of one type and
convert them efficiently into another
and the classic example of which most
people are aware is the catalytic
converter in a car which takes the
exhaust from the engine which is very
high in carbon monoxide and nitrous
oxide and convert those into carbon
dioxide and other forms of nitrogen that
are not as toxic to the environment or
to people I think the easiest route for
us to have impact is to be synergistic
in our look at the problem to understand
that there is value to be derived from
taking different technologies putting
them together taking not just
technologies and putting them together
but working with systems people to put
them together properly and then working
with policy people to understand how to
get technology from the laboratory into
society because the policy part of it
really dictates to a large extent how
the country and society accepts new
technologies